hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to honey pop apparently
cuz huniepop is how idiots pronounce it
well that's me so I'm gonna pronounce it
huniepop from now on so I got I don't
know why this is the only thing that I
carry on me what a sad life I live no
girls yet girl finder that's so creepy
that's so creepy it's like like that I
was gonna say it was like Grindr but
that would lead to a lot of things like
I don't use grinders so how would I know
about Grindr but apparently I've read I
read I brought a joke that Grindr like
dad told that by that British comedian
on Oh
this is like it's like GPS you could see
how close the net and the nearest gay
man is away from you
anyway back to huniepop hello everybody
I'm just gonna get on those this date
because I'm making this awkward for
everybody including you lady all right I
was just trying to look cool I don't
even know what this machine does go
ahead oh did I promise not to be an ass
oh no forgive me saying this but your
body strap I don't know too many girls
who work out with earrings on these are
not good things to say why would I say
this then again I just set up set up
nice boobs lady
okay so earrings hands are mad sweaty
knees weak palms are sweaty the
spaghetti on my spaghetti already you
want some spaghetti monster JD if I can
pull myself off the couch long enough
the damn tree you have to try one of the
yoga classes thank you here the
instructor is awesome I think you dig it
if you like being in a room with a bunch
of sweaty girls that other chick that
was here just a second ago since she was
in range the honey
started tracking her location - so after
you're done here with this girl
you can go catch up with her to just
bust out the honeybee and check out the
girl finder see ya your most desired
trait talent well that's out the window
least desired trait romance damn there
goes my hopeless romantic this unique
gift type o Mexico
loves gift type goodness okay why is
alcohol tolerance there that shouldn't
be there this game is weird questions
aren't very good that was my favorite
character from Nettie let's ask your
weight I wonder how good this concern
well you just told me you said oh I
gotta remember oh I'd have to be an
idiot
haven't eat anything in like 150 years
methinks you might be exaggerating
yeah I'm trying I'm trying my best
I'm really few on dirty magazine seaweed
I couldn't give you a measuring cup oh
no no no no what you want okay I would
love to take you I'm girl gets Hannah
Janet she's hungry check the store to
see if there any food items see my life
Oh food oh okay
oh she wouldn't want that no she took
classy she wants some some health she
want some health in her face damn it
there's not much healthier she said like
anything so that you just can't stand Oh
he exterminated there's nothing more
boring than a Shire nerdy girl I don't
like pitches it's like holy [ __ ] chill
out [ __ ] oh man there we go nothing
more boring than a Shire a nerdy girl
I'm sure I do you don't know me what are
you talking about also oh you want some
more anything you want a hamburger or a
big goal I'm getting hot water
watermelon watermelon shove it in your
face
that stuff goes right to your hips okay
how about a big ol sure you were sure
you were what's going to date Oh me two
also also where am I am I having a
stroke
potatoes okay it's so cool that you like
to hike too
so cool that you still holding your
boobs cuz that's like my favorite thing
yay take that my power blast of love
apparently for some reason is this
working on you I hope this actually
becomes really reality this was all
there was - oh man what a what a bizarre
and sad life all right I need to rack up
some combos here he's really cute so
imbued with fairy magic kinda seems a
lot like radiation but definitely
definitely not radiation I can guarantee
you probably most definitely not
radiation
[Music]
you know instead of talking to people
why wouldn't you do this I like that she
flinches every time I thrust my weird
voodoo magic at her ya giggle at
whatever I did I only got four moves
left I'm not gonna be able to complete
this I need another gift failure failure
that's pretty much what I got a new
message from cue everyday you go on is
gonna be more challenging than the last
if you don't improve your traits you're
gonna blow it trust me well how was what
I was hoping for but I guess that's not
what I want you can use the honey no
honey I don't know what's an automatic
relationship deal-breaker for you I
don't think there's anything that can't
be worked on
[Applause]
amazing okay I'm done with you I'm gonna
go meet this other girl ut-oh super
awesome day keep holding them boobs up
you got it okay
Oh Masumi I'm glad I ran into you have
you had a chance to grade our exams yet
remind me what that was gone again
you know the conservation of whatever
you call it oh yeah yeah I think those
are on my desk somewhere oh okay
do you know when you might be able to
get them back to us later next week
probably I'm sure you did fine
Tiffany you think I hope so I don't know
I was having trouble with some of the
material do you know what we're going
over next week I'd like to try and get a
head start this time next week I don't
know yet
actually I have a pounding headache
right now can we do this later please
yeah okay sorry to bother you miss Yumi
no it's fine I'll talk to you later okay
we're serious oh that schoolgirl uniform
is a little on the nose don't you think
it's cute though one two so uh bonus
points
this is your classic girl next door
situation she's nice so don't say
anything to scare her I haven't seen you
around here before
are you starting this semester no I'm a
random stranger creeping on cavesson not
aa handsome they call me
no don't worry about it I'm all done
with classes for now okay my name is
Tiffany by the way I noticed from that
conversation I was eavesdropping on
hopefully I'll see you around campus
yeah indeed hey you want to talk some
more about things and stuff I love
talking about things what do you think
your biggest weakness is oh this is
where I turned my weakness into my
greatest strength probably everything so
I won't forget Tiffany Mae I'm gonna
forget that I'm the worst about names no
nothing how much do you weigh what are
you study why is watermelon it's
watermelon let's do it wait what are we
doing
wait what I blacked out for a little bit
there what what are we doing Tiffany may
give me money
Tiffany may it's so pretty here also
nice to sure let's not fail this date
that's the only thing I asked all right
so I gotta set up combos right off the
get-go give me a second here
this I've never actually played one of
these types of games before so that's my
excuse right now I know I don't have a
lot of excuses but I haven't I have some
so I'm gonna use I'm just the worst hey
is that real blonde
shut up if you don't shut up I'll make
you a deal every time you give a girl a
gift that she loves I'll have one of our
interns send to present to something use
on dates
[Music]
okay so that's all for honey pops this
episode uh just call the simple should
monument failures Lake Martin will never
love ever period too bad phase all right
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know how badly I'm doing
in the comments below oh it's bad and
thanks again everyone and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
I didn't connect
yeah just it just doesn't